[Music]  I'm patty Bedell  and I'm not your typical pageant queen  there are things about me that I wish  that I could change but I can't she's  sort of the most amazing girl I've ever  met  yeah sounds horrible you're a beauty  queen with a hot boyfriend it doesn't  matter what I look like my life is a  total mess I am a murder suspect okay  what yeah did you do it no of course I  didn't nothing can change who I am or  what I've done  let the past drag you down we're leaving  all the drama behind she's still my car  she's been through a lot I decided to  take control of my life if anything  about death or destruction I had to  focus on my future and then who knows  what I could  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh  you can get away with a paparazzo that  just never really does get old  I know Patti she's a lot of things but  she's not a killer  [Music]  get excited that was [ __ ] awesome  [Music]  [Music]